what is circle and then talk to us about
the suite of products that you guys have
built
for various financial organizations to
use yeah no no problem thank you yeah so
uh circle is a global financial
technology firm we've been operating in
the crypto and digital currency space
for about eight years since 2013
um have built a number of platforms and
products um you know today we operate
the largest uh regulated dollar digital
currency in the world aka dollar stable
coin which is
uh usd coin or usdc which is about 33
billion in circulation and
accounts for a huge amount of the kind
of payments of settlement activity and
in blockchain transactions and payments
and defy and markets and and more and
more other types of activities we we
operate that we also provide
accounts for businesses
that want to be using
dollar digital currency and other crypto
as a core part of how they hold value
their treasury accounts as well as
payment utility through through payment
account functionality and we
offer that in a number of different ways
but you know we fundamentally offer it
as a set of apis and platforms that
developers can build on top of so
whether you're a startup that's building
an nft market or you're an established
fintech that wants to build in support
for things like stable coins and crypto
into your own products and services we
offer that
set of apis that connect the existing
banking system the card networks the
bank networks things like that into uh
blockchain native digital currency you
know payments settlement and treasury
kind of services and i think the last
piece here that that i would note in in
that area is
we have a treasury product which is
circle yield which provides a way for
businesses specifically that want to
allocate
uh dollars into usdc based lending
markets and generate high yield
on on their dollars and usdc and then
last but not least we also operate one
of the largest fundraising platforms for
startups in the united states a product
called seed invest
which has uh grown quite a bit over the
past couple of years and we're excited
about continuing to help startups build
and grow their companies also
increasingly using more and more
kind of digital native approaches
got it and kevin last week when we
talked you talked a little bit about um
kind of using these stable coins to
generate yield like jeremy was just
talking about talk to us about what are
you guys actually doing with usdc and
how does that work
so i'm actually one of those business
accounts on um
on circle
probably one of the earlier ones that
the biggest problem most
let's call them institutional clients
half with usdc
is a compliance infrastructure that
locks into their systems so you know my
operating company i'm no different than
many millions of businesses i have a
compliance officer because i'm an
investor in all kinds of financial
services that are issuers and so
i have to be able to mark to market
at four o'clock my compliance officer
has to see the positions
and then send that report off to the
auditors who are external that would
sign those docs and then report to the
regulator and the various geographies we
operate in
the the trouble with usdc or any
stablecoin for me just you know a year
ago was
what platform can i plug into my
compliance department with is it is it
going to be a bunch of decentralized
systems where i'm trying to convince my
auditor that this is compliant and i
wasn't able to i simply wasn't i could
not get them on board for using the
traditionally decentralized it was only
when i met the team at circle and jeremy
down at uh in february in florida that
we started the dialogue with my own
internal compliance
and then eventually our auditors and
we're still in the in the startup test
phase we were actually you know putting
more and more dollar amounts in
to prove that this works and that you
can actually
uh do it on a daily basis you can open
up your accounts you can see your
positions you can see where you're on or
offside and
right now
you know currently we're waiting for the
regulator to rule on
usdc right i'm trying to convince my own
compliance department that if you don't
want to treat it as money market then
treat it as a stock and the only reason
i'm doing all this work and that i'm
involved with this is
i have a lot of cash sitting around now
because we took we drew down our
our commercial real estate portfolio
materially over the last year and a half
and our alternative for cash is 21 basis
points which doesn't even beat inflation
so we are looking for a solution like
this and all the rest of this work
is working with compliance and
regulators and infrastructure and and
getting this thing on side and so
i'm trying to
you know
drag my
compliance people and auditors out of
the dark into the light on this thing
and that's the good news but the even
more interesting news is how much of
this usdc has grown even since i started
i mean jeremy correct me if i'm wrong
but you're closing in on 30 billion
dollars here and that means there's a
lot of people doing the same thing i'm
doing
and we're not even
you know
we're not on side yet and that means the
potential is
100 200 500 times bigger so
that's where we're at and
i think the potential of circle is huge
i intend to become a shareholder as soon
as
uh the already disclosed back uh
despacks i'll be part of that pipe and
it's a great business and i think it's a
great solution and i think
we'll know more
in the in the months and years ahead on
how usdc grows into a payment system
jeremy talk to us about how big it
actually is right now
yeah so you so usdc i mean just to give
you some perspective
the beginning of 2020 right as the
pandemic was coming
usdc
was about you know 400 500 million
in circulation um we 10xed last year so
we grew from 400 million to 4 billion in
circulation so january 1st literally of
this year there were 4 billion usdc in
circulation
today we're nosing up against 33 billion
usdc in circulation so on track again
for roughly another 10x year of growth
this year and and we've seen over a
trillion dollars in transactions done
with usdc on public blockchains that's
not including all the volume that
happens on exchanges and things like
that so
we really have seen
extraordinary growth uh you know in that
and and as as kevin was was saying you
know um you know people are
are seeing that stable coins are an
extremely efficient way to settle
transactions around the world in the
same way we can exchange data on the
internet we can now exchange value
but it's also you know tapping into
these crypto capital markets and the
demand that exists for digital dollars
in these markets to obviously create
uh you know these kind of fixed income
type opportunities uh for people with
their stable points
got it and when you guys start to think
about this obviously individuals is kind
of a no-brainer they can move quickly
they can determine hey i want a higher
yield uh businesses seem to be um
becoming interested kevin you're doing a
great job kind of uh highlighting how
your business is thinking about it is
this something where we believe that
every corporation uh that's publicly
traded um you know a lot large sovereign
wells large endowments foundations
pension funds etc they will all start to
kind of get in the game here as well uh
or is this something that is more so
private market companies and individuals
and that's where we think really kind of
the addressable market is i mean i'll
touch on part of that i'm sure kevin's
got great perspective on this too uh
which you know my view here is that
the shift to
digital currency based payment and
treasury infrastructure which is
essentially to say
uh businesses that connect to the
internet
are going to increasingly not just with
their digital content and their software
and their information services they're
going to move their financial services
entirely to internet native
infrastructure that as that happens
every single internet savvy business in
the world
is going to store value in digital
currency is going to transact in digital
currency and is absolutely going to use
it as a cash management and a treasury
type infrastructure so we think the
total addressable market is every
internet connected business in the world
from startups to the biggest public
companies to more precisely though i
think um today we're seeing
um you know it's an interesting
bifurcation when i look at the the kinds
of businesses that are signing up for
this in the early access period which
which kevin as noted he was the very
first customer we signed up which was
which was pretty cool for this new new
capability
it's it is everything it's from startups
that are crypto native uh to
uh uh you know significant financial
institutions and public market companies
and others that are
uh you know looking at ways in which
they can diversify some of their
treasury assets so it's both
institutional asset allocators but also
businesses mainline businesses that see
this as a way to augment what they do
with uh with dollars as well
kevin how are you thinking about sizing
it for your business um and then how do
you think other folks will think about
sizing uh this type of product uh if
they've got large pools of capital but
have kind of different structures from a
company's standpoint
i'd like to put a lot more into usdc but
i can't get my guys on board yet for
getting past
a mandate that we have up to a five
percent waiting in and equity
and they keep pointing the finger at me
saying let the regulator rule on this
thing
because there has been some discussion
in the market regarding stable coins and
i don't really think that all stable
coins are created equally
but that's a different debate you know
there's a lot of of noise uh within the
crypto community about tether and other
situations you're well aware that pomp i
know that
um what i would love to have happen
frankly is that uh
the regulator and i'm not speaking for
jeremy i'm just saying what i'd like to
see happen is simply turn them into a
bank and i can use this as cash
alternative to uh what i would hold on
my
on my balance sheet because i'm not
making anything
on us dollars
i'm able to to land this or
stake it if you wish whatever you want
to call it and make between 5.8 and 6.2
and in other cases if i wish to leave
and use other platforms even more but my
bigger problem and i i can speak to this
from many institutions that i service
the more traditional equity markets at
indexing
we we need a plug and play solution
so that you know we can just say okay
let's open an account with circle
let's put in you know 20 percent of our
cash holdings into usdc let's use it as
a payment system
let's stake it and get some yield on it
that's also in usdc issued i can convert
that back to fiat if i want uh and i but
i don't need anybody hassling me i want
i want the regulator to tell me i'm okay
with it
um
you know jeremy's
well able to deal with them and and
solve it i'm basically betting his horse
is going to win this race i guess
and i'll be already set up and then i
can turn the spigot on and put some real
dough to work uh and because it's it's
small right now as we're learning the
systems and how it works and how the
reporting works but the demand is is
going to be huge and
i'm happy to be you know the first uh
business account i'm happy to be the
guinea pig whatever you want to call it
i just wish that we would get some clear
some clarity um even if it doesn't even
if the regulator didn't have to deal
with bitcoin let's leave that alone
let's just deal with
stable coins let's get a ruling on that
let's get that worked out and let me get
to work on that because because there's
no the train has left the station this
isn't going away let's get on with it
let's rule on it let's tell us what the
rules are let's get moving and and i'm
i'll speak on behalf of sovereign index
and every fine we're all in the same
boat on this
i've got two of my brothers here with me
uh or guy jeremy what were you saying
yeah i was just gonna i was gonna just
chime in on on on a point there which is
just to say um you know
as i think a lot of people know
we went out of our way to um you know to
to build usdc as a sort of electronic
stored value money transmission
technology that was sort of the
state-of-the-art in terms of how
regulation applied to digital currency
firms that were doing this kind of
activity and that's how it's regulated
today which is well understood uh it's
like your balance in a paypal account or
or or stripe or square or others and i
think it's now really getting much much
larger and so you've got um you know the
u.s treasury department you've got the
fed you've got others sort of saying
okay at scale this actually
is is you know ought to be kind of
supervised as a banking activity as a a
special form of banking activity stable
coin
banking activity uh and we agree with
that and as you know we are preparing to
file for a national digital currency
bank charter um and we believe that is
the right approach to the kind of cash
side of this and then the other which is
you know um the the lending of stable
coins either can be a bank activity or
it can be you know structured as
securities that are purchased uh and and
entered into uh like other fixed income
you know products and that's also how
we've structured circle year it's it is
structured as a node purchased agreement
it is uh structured as a security and i
think that's an understandable
instrument uh for corporations that are
uh are utilizing their their cash and
capital in in different ways
got it i've got two of my brothers here
what questions you guys got
hey kevin nice to see you again jeremy
nice to meet you uh jeremy so my
question would be people can earn on
usdc somewhere between six to seven
percent yield kind of depending on the
length of the term so my question would
be
how are you able to do that versus
traditional lending instruments
yeah
it's a great question um and there's
actually a good amount of info out there
on this on on our website and others so
the the way to think about this today
is
the the yields on usdc today are are
driven by demand in the crypto capital
markets and when i say crypto capital
markets i mean all of the different
investing trading lending other capital
market activity that's happening in
digital asset native infrastructure
whether that's on centralized exchanges
or or on d5 and within that arena there
is a very significant amount of dollar
stable point borrowing demand there are
ins in principally from our perspective
very high quality institutional
borrowers and these range from asset
managers and other forms of asset
allocators to
hedge funds to
otc firms electronic markets firms you
know many many other institutional
market participants who want to borrow
dollar stable coins
and put those to work in these markets
and they're willing to pay
uh high interest rates for that and if
and they're willing to pay those high
interest rates because they're actually
generating significantly higher returns
and they can't go to jpmorgan chase or
they can't go to goldman sachs to borrow
stable points and so there is this
intrinsic market demand that exists and
this has existed for years and years and
years i operated one of the largest occ
trading desks for a long time
and we borrowed uh all the time and it
was a really powerful way to augment the
working capital that you had as a firm
and so that that's just going on it's
going on a much much larger level now
there's also a retail dimension to that
which is a lot of the borrowing against
uh protocols like ave and compound and
others
that's very much individuals
we exclusively lend on a wholesale basis
to institutional borrowers uh and i
think what also makes the the approach
that we're taking unique is a it's you
know certainly it's these high interest
rates that are that are you know
you know being paid but secondly we
actually over collateralize
every single every single loan so if
you're lending a million usdc through us
we're actually um
we're getting
1.25 million dollars in bitcoin
collateral against that and we're
constantly adjusting the amount of btc
based on intraday price movements to
ensure that we're always in that 125
percent collateralization so not only is
it a uh uh you know a high yield it's
also a secured uh over collateralized uh
you know um you know you know asset as
well so i think that also makes it
pretty interesting
john what questions you got yeah nice to
meet you both hello kevin again um
so there's about 32 billion usdc in
circulation can you talk about what
actually backs that um and then going
forward will that change at all or be
consistent
yeah absolutely so um
just a high level of way to think about
this is
when we
launched usdc over three years ago we
did it
and have operated it under as i
described to you earlier
the regulations that exist by banking
supervisors throughout the united states
so state
money transmission regulation so the
same regulation that applies to the
roughly 35 billion dollars that paypal
holds on its balances the however many
billion that square holds and so on same
regulations and those regulations have
require us
to maintain a one for one reserve
in dollar denominated assets
that are liquid such that we can always
provide
that dollar uh in ex you know that that
dollar uh in exchange for an electronic
money stored value instrument so there
is a regulatory framework around this
we've been examined audited uh
constantly report that both with the
banking regulators and our and our
public company owners and then we took
another step which was to basically
every month provide a report not not an
audit because you don't get audited uh
every month but a uh an attestation on
that in fact we're meeting those
obligations and it's on a one-for-one
basis with the digital currency units or
tokens outstanding so we've been doing
that for several years um
the the state laws um essentially
bound you to a very conservative
underlying uh set of permissible
investments so you're bound to a very
very conservative base of permissible
investments and if you go outside of
that you're breaking the law and so
we've always been inside of that
we've based on market feedback as well
as sort of i think where we think
regulators are going on this and this is
through what i'll kind of call
public sector signaling policy maker
preferences proposed regulations on
stable coins that we're seeing in the uk
and europe and singapore and other
places we um where this is going is
that
stable coin reserves if you want to call
it that uh should be in kind of cash and
cash equivalents exclusively that is
what we're seeing uh demanded uh and
that's what we've moved to uh so we are
a hundred percent in cash and cash
equivalents uh and we're committed to to
remain in that uh position uh until we
see regulations say otherwise i mean i
think this is gonna be a moving target
over time as these get to you know if
it's uh you know
half a trillion or trillion uh dollars
of value in these dollar digital
currencies um what is the underlying
kind of risk liquidity fiduciary model
that the federal reserve u.s treasury
and others will want to see
that will evolve obviously significantly
over time but today just to you know
take a long answer and make it very
short it's a hundred percent in cash and
cash equivalents
awesome kevin when you think about usdc
we've talked a lot about uh the yield
component and thinking of it almost like
an investment asset that you can drive
that yield on is there a world where if
you could convince the
partners or the customers or your kind
of business
transaction uh participants to take usdc
would you move a material part or 100 of
all of your wires and kind of legacy
banking infrastructure payments to
something like usdc where you could do
it more instantaneous cheaper faster etc
yeah of course i would but i can't do
that now i mean let me explain what the
potential from my point of view as a
user of the product
one of the greatest frustrations that
i've articulated over the last couple of
years is what i do in
foreign markets on equities i i
have a
an index that involves 50 large-cap
european stocks that unfortunately or
fortunately whatever you want to say are
three different currencies in swiss
francs and euros and british pounds one
of the largest friction points for me
in rebalancing these indices
is the fact that i have to go back and
forth through fx costs for friction of
fx trading
if if regulators could get behind a
digital payment system that would allow
me to own the securities in let's say
usdc at a price that's completely
transparent and liquid
um
i could avoid that friction in
perpetuity and and it would be a much
more
efficient way to do business to settle
in in a universal digital currency now i
know that sounds you know euphoric but
ultimately we need to get there and and
the u.s dollar today is that currency it
still is
um you know many people speculate its
future but for hundreds of years it's
been the currency that people settle on
for all kinds of commodities and
services
it's very inefficient for what i'm doing
uh in these markets to to pay these
these fx costs which vary by the hour
and i see no value added and so
to me
let's get moving let's let's lead the
world in this in this process and this
efficiency i hate the idea that um our
regulator would hold us back against
innovation when clearly it's needed
and on the baseline of usdc which you
know there are rules for money market
funds when you go to cash in your you
know brokerage account you get swept if
you wish into a money market account
that has rarely broken a buck and there
are rules
i see no reason we can't apply that kind
of regulatory environment to usdc
and you know have that settle that way
and of course i would put more into it
because i don't know where rates are
going to be once the regulator you know
rules on usdc they probably go down
you're not going to get six percent
anymore because there'll be a flood of
institutional demand but it's going to
be better than what i'm getting on us
cash is my assumption and in addition to
that could be far more efficient as a
payment system across a wide range of
different uses i mean the use cases here
are very broad and so
you know one way to look at it and i've
tried to convince in my own
conversations with regulators and most
of us have these ongoing dialogues in
our day-to-day business
to start thinking about usdc as software
really efficient software if you're
willing to invest in microsoft and i've
said this before in google why aren't
you investing in software that has such
promise and that's basically what in my
view it's a personal opinion but when i
invest in circle as a business i'm
investing in software that provides
tremendous productivity and efficiency
in in a business i've been in for
decades financial services and the same
for the chain for all of the other
investments i'm making in
cryptocurrencies coins tokens and you
know blockchain itself
it's it's software to me and i think
it's a necessary investment and i hope
that our regulator our regulators
see that we should lead the world in
developing these protocols and these
standards and help us do so
jeremy one of the big questions that
people have in the chat is how does
circle make money and how does uh being
in cash and cash equivalents 100 until
you get that clarity from regulators how
does that affect your ability to make
money either positively or negatively
yeah so there are really a few buckets
of income for circle the first is that
usdc infrastructure so we're the
principal operator of that market
infrastructure there's as noted 32 going
on 33 billion
it's in a very conservative posture and
the best way to think about that is yes
we generate income from that and it's
highly interest rate sensitive right so
like other financial services cyclicals
if interest rates rise there's there's
certainly you know
more income potential
from that piece but we think of that as
really like um you know we're trying to
operate a market infrastructure that
everyone can can take advantage of the
second piece is through circle account
we monetize in two ways one is people
who take advantage of our yield services
and who are lending usdc and generating
income uh
you know from those interest rates uh
and spread capture in that the second is
through what we call our transaction
services so
more and more businesses want to
integrate the existing financial rails
with things like usdc
and blockchain infrastructure so we have
a broad set of transaction services that
connect all those provide
platforms and apis people can build on
top of and we monetize that based on
essentially usage feeds how much are you
using those transaction services how
much are you using um that the wallet
infrastructure the storage
infrastructure the blockchain
infrastructure and our fiat rails so
that's another big category of income so
you've got the treasury services the
transaction services you have usdc uh
you know interest income and then the
third is basically um we have a take
rate for every dollar of capital that we
raise for startups we've helped startups
raise hundreds of millions of dollars
that's growing really nicely that's a
really exciting business uh our
investment platform our seed capital
platform uh and so we have a take rate
uh in that as well which is another
source of income for the company got it
so you got kind of a diversified revenue
stream here which makes a ton of sense
kevin when you think about uh investing
in circle in that pipe and i know some
of this thoughts to play out uh over
time um but equity i'm assuming that you
as an investor are thinking about
getting that kind of crypto exposure
like we talked about last week that
would be an equity investment which
doesn't go in the same bucket as let's
say your stable coin cash position
that's generating yield which may not go
in the same bucket as let's say your
minor position as well and so you're
kind of actually in some weird way not
thinking of crypto as one single bucket
but it's actually your stocks bonds
currencies and commodities you're
actually getting it infiltrated by these
companies and technologies across all of
those various buckets is that a fair way
to look at it
it is fair but there's also a personal
philosophy at play here you know when i
started my wine business i didn't own
any vineyards now i do
i i i like to eat my own cooking i like
to own the vertical i like to own the
infrastructure that supports the
business
so
why wouldn't i want to own a piece of
circle if i'm using usdc to me it just
makes intuitive sense and as opposed to
making uh you know five or six percent
interest on usdc as i as i lend it out
over a long period of time if usdc
becomes a standard i hope it will i'll
enjoy the capital gains associated with
owning part of the infrastructure i i
have been a stalwart on this if you're
going to get involved in bitcoin that is
simply one asset and i am very
diversified now into minors their
equities uh some of the coins they own
uh certainly why wouldn't i want a piece
of circle if i'm going to be using usdc
as i said earlier but you you have to
you have to make a binary decision and
there are many in the financial services
market that haven't
done the 180 that i have that have
convinced they continue to try and
convince themselves that there is no
future
in in this in this software technology
there's no future in cryptocurrencies
there's no future in bitcoin there's
there's only regulatory hell ahead i
don't feel that way i i have a
completely different view of the world i
see the efficiency the productivity
potential
and for me if i look at my just you know
the the the time i spent
today at our ten o'clock deal meeting uh
40
of that hour was just looking at the
at the crypto deals that that were being
shown we have a we're very fortunate to
have very very large deal flow
and it it's almost half of what we look
at now placing bets on all kinds of
different approaches
of some you know
in recent times immutable holdings and
wonderful and hopefully circle soon and
some of the coins we've talked the
miners we've talked about that i own now
this is this is going to be a 20
waiting in our operating company as an
and i've said this before and i'll say
it again
call it the 12th sect of the s p that's
what this is and in my world in my
compliant world i can own up to 20
of this sector and be compliant and
that's where i'm going end of this year
seven we'll see what happens next year
but pomp included in that 20 percent are
equities coins tokens chain developers
you name it you know it's just it's uh
it's the 12th sector of the s p but
nobody's called it that yet
you you come on here and you tell us and
flex you got a winery and then you tell
us the 12th sector i mean you are all
time we're gonna have to bring you on
like once a week that if you're gonna
drop bombs like that if you like that
video wait did you see my next one don't
forget to click right over here and
subscribe